[Musique]
au liban il est connu comme le loup
blanc son nom michel eleftériadès c'est
le patron du music hall un des hauts
lieux de la vie nocturne à beyrouth il
est aussi producteur businessman
agitateur politique un personnage
mystérieux mais aussi très influent
rencontre avec le maître des soirées
libanaise endiablé il a surtout une
histoire comme souvent les hommes et les
hommes caractérisée comme cela ils ont
une vie derrière eux hall le cas de
michel c'est que il a eu une vie il a
toujours été résistant il ait il n'a
même combattu n'était pas toujours du
bon côté c'est à dire celui qui gagne
est mais ils étaient résistants chaque
fois qu'on me parle du liban je demande
des nouvelles de ce phénomène
eleftériadès heures pour savoir ce qui
devient j'ai fait donc c'est des loges
du militant les militants de base qui
l'a été du musicien de l'écrivain
l'homme abatteurs des beaux-arts aussi
de peinture
je vois aussi que c'est plus que cela et
que certainement le dans le liban qui
vient il devrait occuper une place plus
grande
je pense que michel eleftériadès fait
partie de ces personnes qui si elle
n'existait pas il faudrait les inventer
je dirais de lui que c'est véritablement
un cosmopolite au sens le plus noble du
terme un
internationaliste qui en a eu assez de
ses divisions de l'humanité
alors son interview je réponds à vos
questions depuis mon lunch le
championnat ou en plein coeur de
beyrouth la capitale du liban
on ne peut plus parler du poids de la
parole diplomatique française au moyen
orient elle n'existe plus c'est la
parole américaine c'est ils sont devenus
des porte parole de la parole américaine
c'est devenu de tout petits pions
des poissons pilotes qui qui navigue
avec le grand requin dans l'espoir de
recueillir des miettes c'est vraiment
pathétique la france avait un grand rôle
dans cette région du monde la diplomatie
française a eu
son heure de gloire c'était une
référence dans la diplomatie mondiale
c'est devenu maintenant des comme disait
mon ami jacques vergès la [__] des
américains
ce qui s'est passé en syrie récemment
a été une grande humiliation
pour les états unis et ses alliés
je sais pas comment ils vont pouvoir
justifier toute cette excitation
tous ces préparatifs pour partir en
guerre et puis du jour au lendemain
après que le l'ours russe et mon
précédent ils sont se sont soudain
assagi il serait devenu soudain des
grandes idées des gens qui qui qui qui
ont qui parle de dialogue qui veulent
une solution pacifique pour la crise en
syrie
donc je sais pas comment
comment être crédible après un tel
revirement
la france la politique être de la france
est une politique mercenaires
la france ne peut plus vivre comme à
l'époque de du colonialisme est la plus
des colonies qui peuvent lui permettre
de vivre dans l'opulence
les français devront travailler plus il
devrait respecter les investisseurs il
devrait créer un système qui respecte
les ambitieux quand on parle la longueur
de journée de petit petit petit en
parlant du café de la sortie du dîner de
la toux la culture du petit on peut pas
exiger du grand et vouloir vivre comme
des nababs
maintenant ils essaient le
néocolonialisme au lieu de partir eux
mêmes en guerre ils envoient des déserts
mouillé
à des proxy à des mercenaires qui font
la guerre à leur place dans l'espoir que
c'est une phase mercenaires au pouvoir
ils vont pouvoir rafler des contrats
pour reconstruire le pays pour exploiter
les ressources naturelles de ces pays
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait un peu avec la
libye et ils ont pensé que ce que ce
système qu'il va faire best best
practice de ce système est d'essayer de
de l'utiliser ailleurs mais la syrie
n'est pas la libye ce qui peut être
valable dans un pays où l'armée et
n'est pas une vraie armée ne peut pas
être appliquée dans des pays qui ont de
vraies armes et qui ont des gens qui ont
qui sont plus
qui analysent mieux ce qui se passe et
on peut mieux qu'elle foule sans people
first time
c'est à dire que il ils peuvent le faire
une deux fois mais la troisième fois la
quatrième phase à devient un peu
difficile à faire à faire passer la
chose même si
si le clown bernard henri lévy
fait des prouesses incroyables sur des
chaînes internationales pour expliquer
que bachar al assad est un islamiste
dangereux même s'il va faire de grands
discours sur les valeurs de sa
philosophie humaniste est sûre il est
plus crédible il est il est complètement
un grillé et c'est dommage que que la
france qui a
deux grands philosophes encore
aujourd'hui et qui a eu des philosophes
qui ont changé l'histoire de l'humanité
c'est dommage que qu'elle accepte que
quelqu'un comme bernard henri lévy
puisse encore passer sur des chaînes
internationales avec en dessous french
philosophie donc ça c'est une honte pour
l'histoire de la philosophie française
et pour la culture française en général
en général je suis contre
l'impérialisme qui découle d'une des
super puissances
la russie en est une mais quand je
compare la situation actuelle à la
situation de l'uni polarité américaine
qu'on a vécu les dernières vingt trente
années je préfère avoir une russie forte
avec un nouveau tsar avec quelqu'un qui
a un kaka qui s'est imposé sa volonté ça
limite les dégâts le pouvoir absolu
corrompt absolument
là les états unis étaient devenus très
arrogant parce que
il savait qu'il pouvait partir
là où ils veulent sans jamais avoir de
contrat entre qu'ils pouvaient faire les
erreurs qu'il titille l'utile pas faire
sans être puni et ça ça c'est très
dangereux parce que
des millions de morts sont appelés
collatérale d'un match donc pour eux
c'est dénombré de collateral damage
c'est c'est pas grand chose mais pour
nous qui vivons dans cette région du
monde
c'est nos familles et nos amis c'est des
vies entières qui sont qui sont broyés
et ils l'ont fait ils ont fait à
plusieurs reprises il voulait continuer
à le faire jusqu'à ce que la russie et
poutine viennent leur dire non poutine
est un grand leader le monde ça fait
longtemps que le monde n'a pas connu de
vrais grands leaders la france avait eu
une tradition de deux chefs d'état de
grandes cultures qui avait du charisme
qui avaient du talent qui qui avait du
style
mais maintenant cesser c'est vraiment
des médiocres là on a eu deux deux
médiocres pas nous les français ont eu
deux je me sens un peu français quelque
part vu que ma culture et mes lectures
sont françaises
c'est triste c'est triste que la france
n'est pas son poutine qui pourrait
redorer un peu le blason de la france
c'est triste de devoir un chef d'état
français qui sait pas marcher sur un sur
un tapis et qu'une femme doit remettre
dans la bonne direction
c'est triste de voir un un chef français
qui qui ressemble à rien qu'ils qui est
là qui n'a même pas compris qu'il y
avait un accord qui était en train
d'être signés entre les russes et les
américains et qui même quand les les
américains avaient rappelé leurs leur
cerbère lui il était toujours là à
aboyer il est encore tout excité c'est
vraiment triste pour la france et c'est
par amour de la france que je le dis
on
peut pas parler d'une perception
unifiée dans la région
quand une décision russe est applaudi
par une partie de la population moyenne
orientale
il ya notre parti qu'il a maudit et vice
versa
il y à il ya deux axes actuellement il
ya un axe
russes chinois iraniens plusieurs partis
d'amérique latine
et dans la région il ya des gens qui
adhèrent à cet axe il ya l'autre axe où
il ya les états unis israël la france
d'épée à l'angleterre dpd pays comme ça
donc il ya partout dans le monde il ya
un fort clivage entre ces deux ces deux
axes et leurs partisans
[Musique]
on
sous prétexte de démocratie
l'occident est en train de d'armé et
d'apporter son appui à des hordes
barbares
qui pratiquent le cannibalisme qui
pratiquent
des
les comportements médiévaux parfois même
encore bien plus plus ancien des choses
de la guerre du feu des coupeurs de
têtes sévissent en syrie
il applique
ce qu'il appelle la charia qui n'a rien
à voir avec la vraie chaleur charia
islamique c'est des malades qui viennent
du monde entier pour détruire
une civilisation magnifique qui a
survécu à plein d'invasion et qui est
arrivé intact jusqu'à nous je parle de
deux villages comme al oula ou l'araméen
la vraie langue du christ est encore
parlé
et ces gens là vont en quelques mois
détruire cet héritage
soutenue par l'occident sous prétexte de
démocratie
on nous parle de
démocratie on parle d' établir une
démocratie en syrie
alors que kiel son allié de l'arabie
saoudite du qatar de plein de pays qui
n'ont rien à voir avec la démocratie
la série s'était pas byzance
la série s'est pas
c'est pas la suède
la syrie d'assad mais au moins c'est un
pays où il y avait le droit de la femme
où les minorités pouvait vivre bien les
minorités religieuses sexuelles et
autres où il y avait une classe moyenne
où on pouvait parler un tant soit peu de
politique on n'a pas le droit d'insulter
le président mais il ya plein de pays et
de démocratie et de grands pays qui ont
une grande culture de tolérance et de
libre de parole libre qui ne tolère pas
ils n'acceptent pas d'insulter les chefs
d'état donc ce n'était pas vraiment la
série ce n'était pas un despotisme telle
qu'on essaie de le dépeindre maintenant
et même si ça avait été le cas on ne
peut pas sous prétexte de faire tomber
un régime qui n'est pas très
démocratique
faire alliance avec des sauvages avec
des des gens tels qu'on voit maintenant
en syrie
je suis
contre une intervention contre toutes
les interventions
je pense que un pays qui un peuple qui
ne peut pas lui même se libérer un
peuple qui ne peut pas lui même faire sa
révolution
ne mérite pas d'être aider
un peuple qui ne sait pas se respecte et
le fils se mettre en ligne
quand on voit aussi en syrie ou dans le
plein de pays arabes on voit que ok ils
se mettent ils se mettent en ligne mais
c est les
horizontales la ligne au lieu d'être
verticale c'est à dire que il
il faut commencer par éduquer les
peuples avant de leur donner le droit au
vote
ça fait des années que je dis que si
demain il ya des élections dans le monde
arabe c'est les islamistes qui vont
prendre le pouvoir il faut commencer par
aider les peuples
à travers la culture la culture est
primordial ceux qui préparent la culture
c'est
celle des philosophes c'est des
écrivains c'est
s'aider des intellectuels qui peuvent
créer chez chez les peuples une
conscience qu'ils peuvent installer une
conscience qui prépare les révolutions
temps des révolutions
dans dans cette partie du monde
ceux qui ont
ce qu'ils vont voter ils vont écouter la
parole du cher
et même dans même pour les chrétiens du
de notre région c'est aussi c'est la
parole du curé or le curé et les chaires
ont jamais mené à très loin c'est les
philosophes c'est c'est des gens qui qui
sont qui ont une plus grande ouverture
d'esprit qui peuvent mener les peuples
vers des démocraties à la scandinave ou
à l'européenne loi de la démocratie où
il ya le respect de l'individu il ya le
respect de 2,2
de la diversité de la diversité de
l'autre mais si c'est la parole du cher
et la parole du curé bon jour là la
nouvelle
la nouvelle constitution
il ya plus à mon avis ya plus
son direct occidentale en syrie
et même à l'époque où je suis très ami
avec des gens des nations unies des gens
très hauts placés et j'étais un débat où
il voulait savoir s'il fallait évacuer
au liban ou non parce qu'il y avait
toutes ses préparatifs de guerre
américaine et j'ai insisté et j'ai parié
avec eux qui aura pas de frappes
américaines personne
personne ne peut supporter ça aucun chef
occidental ne peut prendre le risque
maintenant de le faire déclencher une
troisième guerre mondiale
je connais bien les russes j'ai vécu un
peu là-bas
et je sais que quand un président russe
dit niet ça veut dire niet sait pas où
on verra et peut-être et donc
ils peuvent pas le faire les
conséquences auraient été désastreuse
un peu on a vu déjà le résultat en irak
en séries ça a été encore pire
et pas que la syrie quand je dis la
série s'arrêtait le liban aussi et ça
aurait embrasé toute là toute la région
donc je pense qu'on a évité le pire
j'espère que en séries ça va pas être
une guerre de longue
durée ce qu'on appelle low intensity
conflict qui peut durer très longtemps
c'est pas une vraie vraie guerre mais
ces cds banc de mad max qui se déplace
et qui sèment la terreur qui brûlent des
villages qui qui violent qui coupe des
têtes qui qui font des délires et ils
sont très difficiles à
éliminer parce que ils continuent à
venir il ya de tout le monde
arabo-musulman
et ses
réservoirs illimité ça peut faire la
sphère de plusieurs pays d'envoyer
d'envoyer au
chez le charcutier tout tout ce stock de
potentiels terroristes mais ça coûte
très très cher à la syrie et au liban
aussi à tous les pays de la région
j'espère que la russie va pouvoir
imposer qu'elle a assez de cartes pour
pouvoir faire pression et arrêter ce
délire en syrie je pense que assad ne
peut pas revenir
aux à l'état
à la
légitimité qu'il avait avant avant les
événements en syrie il va devoir faire
des concessions c'est le cas dans toutes
les négociations
dans toutes les négociations les deux
parties sont appelées à faire des
petites concessions et je pense que en
faisant de petites concessions et en
trouvant une sorte de scénario de
nouveau pacte ils peuvent reconstruire
la syrie
il ya des gens à exclure ceux qui ont
détruit leur pays qui ont été des
mercenaires à la solde de 2 des
monarchies du pétrodollar ou bien des
puissances étrangères
ne n'ont pas leur place dans le nouveau
pays
ça va mettre du temps mais je suis
plutôt optimiste
le flux des réfugiés syriens au liban
est une vraie catastrophe pour le liban
c'est à dire que une population de 3
millions trois millions et demi de deux
libanais ne peut pas accueillir
deux millions de réfugiés c'est un tout
petit pays c'est à peine un département
français
et tout à coup il ya deux millions de
réfugiés démunis qui débarque dans ce
département c'est inconcevable c'est une
catastrophe qu'aucun autre pays n'aurait
pu assimiler il ya ce côté miracle
libanais cette forte résilience des
libanais cette capacité à absorber les
chocs
mais il faut pas exagérer il faut que le
monde entier surtout que ceux qui
qui se considère comme mes amis du
peuple syrien et ceux qui veulent le
bien de la syrie se penche sur ce
problème et viennent en aide
à ces réfugiés à travers le liban
parce que c'est nous qui sommes en train
de payer avec notre économie
avec notre bien-être avec on a déjà
assez payé on a eu quinze ans de guerre
civile la série avait pris part dans
cette guerre civile contre les libanais
donc quand ils ont quand ça se passe
bien pour eux c'est l'armée syrienne qui
envahit le liban et quand ils ont des
problèmes c'est les réfugiés syriens qui
viennent nous envahir donc le discours
peut paraître un peu
nationaliste il peut
dérangé les vierges effarouchées du bon
sentiment et de l'humanitaire et de ce
qu'il faut faire ou ce qu'il faut pas
faire
mais je suis en train d'être réaliste
j'aime bien mon frère mais s'il vient
avec toute sa famille dans ma maison et
il va dormir dans mon lit et s'il veut
le bousiller ma vie je lui dis non il ya
des limites
un invité un réfugié se doit d'être un
peu plus
discret un peu moins envahissant c'est
pas la peine de venir avec les deux
trois voitures de la famille c'est pas
la peine de rouler parce qu'on a des
embouteillages monstres on est un pays
de services on n'a pas deux campagnes
avec des des paysans qui sont en train
de la cultiver quiquet de notre économie
on n'a pas une grande industrie on est
basée sur des services on peut plus
avoir un meeting on peut plus envoyer un
papier a signé d'un endroit à l'autre on
ne peut plus rien faire le moindre
trajet qui est qui prenait 2 3 minutes
en maintenant une heure donc c'est
vraiment une situation alarmante et le
problème c'est que chaque fois que j'en
parle c'est est levée de boucliers et
ses insultes
j'ai de très bonnes relations
ibanez
dans ce lieu même chaque semaine je
rencontre des dizaines d'officiers
je pense que l'espoir
du liban passe par l'armée libanaise que
l'armée libanaise peut vraiment faire un
changement pour le liban que dans un
pays aussi pourri où il ya autant de
corruption où il ya autant de
communautés
où il n'y a plus de repères
là mais peut jouer un grand rôle
j'ai lancé une campagne de soutien à
l'armée libanaise j'ai demandé que
l'armée libanaise prennent le pouvoir
je suis pas
c'est pas par amour de deux de l'armée
en général c'est pas dogmatique comme
approche c'est réaliste c'est un peu
aussi
égoïste parce que je connais
mon intérêt et l'intérêt des libanais
l'armée libanaise est la seule qui peut
garantir la
la survie du liban
avec tous les conflits qui sont autour
du liban c'est un petit pays qui peut
être facilement contrôlé qu'on peut
diriger comme une forteresse
on peut appeler ça un coup d'état mais
il ya une forme de coup d'état qui est
la plus acceptée par tout le monde qui
est le coup d'état gardien c'est quand
des officiers qui plane au pouvoir non
pas par amour du pouvoir ou pour leur
propre intérêt mais qui veulent protéger
ce pays qui veulent être les gardiens
de cet héritage de ce que nos parents
nous ont laissés pour le passé aux
générations futures
t'as pas les générations mais pendant
dix ans
c'est à dire protéger le pays travailler
sur les institutions préparer une
nouvelle génération
de gens à travers une nouvelle culture
une nouvelle approche imposer un livre
commun l'histoire
calmer les le clergé les que le clergé
musulman chrétien enfin tout ou toute
forme de clergé limiter l'action d'aidé
religieux et préparer un nouveau pays ça
prendra le temps qu'il faut et l'armée
donnera de nouveau le pays aux gens il
faut aussi calmer les médias parce que
la liberté d'expression c'est bien mais
ça donne pas le droit à la dire
n'importe quoi il ya des limites
or les libanais et plein de pays arabes
pensent que la liberté d'expression
c'est le droit à l'insulté c'est le
droit au prosélytisme à l'incitation
raciale à l'incitation religieuse or nos
larmes et doit prendre le pouvoir
l'armée doit pouvoir tout contrôler si
on veut que le liban existe toujours
le nourrissant est un projet culturel
social politique philosophique et autres
c'est un projet qui offre des solutions
à plein de problèmes qu'on pensait sans
solution
des solutions faciles
c'est une idée qui
qui est bien sûr qu'il peut s'apparenter
à l'utopie qui est une utopie
actuellement mais je pense que tout
progrès à travers l'histoire de
l'humanité a commencé par être une
utopie et les grandes et grands pas de
l'humanité c'était la réalisation de ces
utopies
ça devient de plus en plus facile
maintenant de communiquer un nouveau
projet le temps du nouristan est
vraiment venu il ya plein de gens qui
sont dégoûtés
par les politiciens par la manière dont
le monde est dirigé et qui pense que on
peut maintenant
rêver et travailler pour la réalisation
d'un projet comme le nourrissant donc ça
peut avoir plusieurs noms mais j'ai
choisi ce nom parce qu'il a un côté
amusant un côté ludique et je pense que
c'est pas mal de de présenter une idée
qui est très sérieuse qui est béton mais
avec un emballage avec une approche un
peu plus légère c'est beaucoup mieux que
de faire ce que font les autres
politiciens c'est à dire servir de la
merde
mais dans un packaging très sérieux donc
vaut mieux
attirer les jeunes
ne pas faire un truc complètement
hermétique exposé d'une manière simple
et non pas simpliste d'une manière
simple des idées complexes des idées
sérieuse des idées qui découlent de
beaucoup d'expérience de philosophie
plutôt que de faire ce que font d'autres
politiciens le savent et je vois parfois
des discours de politicien où il parle
il présenterait bien ils savent très
bien parlé ils ont appris le
langage le parti d'un groupe avec des
spécialistes et ils sont très bien
habillé mais ils disent n'importe quoi
c'est bien quand on analyse quand on
fait une saisie de ce qu'ils ont dit et
qu'on lit le contenu de ce qu'ils ont
dit ça veut vraiment rien dire et ce
truc dans les débats présidentiels où ça
devient ridicule parce que c'est un
concours de qui a la meilleure mémoire
deux points 34% des gens pensent que l
opinion c'est 2.36 cp on s'en fout de
tout ça ça c'est des détails qui n'ont
aucun sens parce que maintenant je vais
sur le mon ordinateur je tape sur google
je googlise
n'importe quelle statistique
je compte tout j'ai pas besoin d'un
perroquet qui viennent de les répéter à
la télévision jusqu'à besoin d'élire
quelqu'un qui acquiert qui a une bonne
mémoire ou quelqu'un qui sait pas j'ai
besoin de gens qui apportent de
solutions or tous ces gens là tous ces
grands chefs et cc des deux partis
européens et ses chefs d'état rapporte
rien mais vraiment rien et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya une sorte de
de nos futurs chez les chez les jeunes
jeunesse open ils sont désabusés ils ont
20 ans et ils sont là à penser
[Musique]
le pourcentage de plus trop quoi qu'ils
auront à la retraite dans 40 ans ils
sont là à faire des manifs pour des
trucs mesquin
mais c'est pas ça qui va changer le
monde c'est parce que ça qui va changer
la vie des gens il faut que les gens
réalisent qu'ils peuvent exiger un grand
changement
la campagne de oprah masse était
changement il ne s'était rien c'est des
changements minimes c'est c'est blanc
bonnet et bonnet blanc sait c'est
exactement la même politique qui
continue à faire mais sous des slogans
qu'ils sont plus intelligents parce
qu'il est plus intelligent que le cas au
breuil qui avait avant lui c'est
difficile d'être plus con que george w
bush donc c'est pas parce qu'il est un
peu plus intelligent qu'on devrait
s'extasier ou que les américains doit se
contenter d'un tel changement c'est pas
parce qu'il est un peu plus basané que
les yankees qui avait avant lui que l'on
doit dire c'est c'est la victoire de du
du rêve de martin luther king et passa
avons parlé martin luther king c'est pas
de prendre un noir de mettre à la rue
même pas noir américain cia c'est un
métis afro-américains qui est qui est
devenu président ce n'était pas ça la
victoire des noirs quand on voit dans
les villes américaines maintenant on
peut toujours voir la misère que vivent
les la population noire les descendants
des esclaves canton quand on voit le
nombre de milliardaires et de
millionnaires blanc qui a et le nombre
de milliardaires noir on voit la
différence qui a et qui continue c'est
pas ça qui échanger nos il faut exiger
un changement un vrai changement soudain
changé c'est ce que les américains ont
changé et ce qui passe ce qui se passe
c'est souvent dans les changements de
chefs d'état ou dans quand on passe d'un
parti à l'autre actuellement c'est qu'on
chance seulement l'écran or les virus
ce qu'on va nous donnerons bien passé
les cas le virus il n'est pas dans
l'écran d'un ordinateur quand on garde
de disque dur quand on garde le même
environnement et qu'on change l'écran on
n'a rien fait il faut un changement
radical
je ne peux pas vivre je peux pas
envisager ma vie sans avoir un combat
noble vivre pour manger boire baiser
c'est pas une vie pour moi c'est pas au
tessin portant lé plaisir dans la vie
c'est important mais je dois avoir une
mission noble tu dois avoir un grand
projet pour continuer à me battre pour
continuer à apprécier
pour continuer à apprécier
d'être sur ses terres donc j'ai besoin
d'un projet comme le nouristan même si
sa réalisation
ne va je vais pas voir la réalisation du
projet mais au moins j'ai le plaisir de
me dire chaque fois que je suis un peu
déprimé chaque fois que je suis agressée
par des gens verbalement que je reçois
des insultes de mérite à ce que je me
sens menacé de dire ça vaut la peine je
suis en train de faire quelque chose de
m un train sur sur les rails et ce train
peut mener l'humanité
vers quelque chose de beau vers ces
lendemains qui chantent vert d un monde
meilleur et je suis convaincu de ce
projet c'est pas une vision que j'ai eu
c'est pas un archange qui est venu nous
visiter la nuit c'est pas des voix que
j'ai entendu c'est basé sur une
expérience personnelle une lutte qui a
mal commencé il ya 30 ans quand j'avais
15 ans c'est des souffrances la
souffrance de perdre des amis de voir
des amis tombés devant soi c'est
des années d'exil c'est
c'est la somme de tout ça qui m'a permis
de penser
la philosophie et le système du
nouristan je sais que ça va apporter
d'aidé un gambien fait à toute
l'humanité et avec la globalisation
maintenant on ne peut plus parler de
bien être une partie de l'humanité et
pas de l'autre parce que ça va générer
des jaloux les voyages très facile
l'internet et la
faire des bonds donc s'il n'y a pas une
répartition des richesses si elle pas
une répartition du bonheur du bien-être
il y aura les pauvres qui vont venir un
jour rendre visite aux riches quand
l'argent ne va pas vers les pauvres
c'est les pauvres qui vont vers l'argent
un voisinage
qui
les quartiers défavorisés
s'ils ont faim ils sortent et ils
viennent dans les beaux quartiers pour
casser la porte ouvrir le réfrigérateur
et ça c'est à l'échelle planétaire
maintenant
avant cela crève la faim ne savait pas
comment vivre les comment vivez comment
vivent les autres mais maintenant dans
la dernière des dernières favelas dans
le dernier des derniers
quartiers populaires d'un pays arabe
qu'ils ont des satellites il voit ce que
les autres à coire les autres aux accès
est ce que ils n'ont pas
il y aura toujours un
des riches et des pauvres mais ce ne
sera pas due à la naissance c'est pas
comme eux un loto une un gars va quand
on est maintenant
en suisse même si on est idiot et
paresseux on sait qu'on va vivre mieux
qu'un génie qui n'est dans quelques pays
africains ou d'en haut
dans des pays défavorisés
j'ai un message pour les enfants pas
pour le gouvernement français je pense
que c'est inutile de
de parler à des gens qui savent bien que
qu'il faut de mauvaises choses mais ils
sont aveuglés par le gain par les
intérêts financiers donc ça sert à rien
avec ces gens là il faut pas il faut
même pas dialoguer ces gens là il faut
les les punir les forcer à changer de
politique parce que on débat avec des
jambes qui ont une idéologie différentes
avec des gens qui sont dans dans leur
tort parce qu'ils n'ont pas compris des
choses mais quelqu'un qui sait avec un à
fieux qui sait que ce qu'il fait est
mauvais c'est pas la peine de lui dire
non il faut pas faire ça il sait déjà
mais c'est peine perdue pour les
français je veux leur dire de ne pas
être
de ne pas se perdre dans les détails
de ne pas sacrifier l'ensemble pour le
détail donc tous leurs départs et les
touts ces clivages qui n'ont plus aucun
sens de droite et de gauche parce que
maintenant quand je vois un je suis pas
je ne suis pas de très près la politique
française même temps quand je vois
parler un politicien français je sais
vraiment pas je sais vraiment plus si le
doigt et de gauche et pourtant on
continue à coller ces étiquettes je vois
parfois maintenant des discours des gens
de l'extrême droite qui s'apparente
vraiment mais comme on peut penser que
c'est des cocos des communistes je vois
des communistes l'extrême droite c'est
donc il faut plus penser avec ces termes
il faut refonder la politique française
il faut refonder la politique européenne
il faut refonder la politique mondiale
la france a une place à occuper dans
dans le panorama mondial
la culture française est une des plus
grandes cultures du monde la renaissance
en 16e siècle des lumières
là le rayonnement de la france ne doit
pas cesser la france doit revenir à ce
qui a fait sa grandeur à ce qui a fait
que la culture française a inspiré plein
de révolution dans le monde ce qui a
fait que cette culture a toujours été
celle des révolutionnaires celle des
gens qui veulent faire évoluer des
sociétés laïques
la laïcité est un concept qui est très
important et sa foi la france a une
place
de choix dans la promotion de la laïcité
cela doit être fait à travers la culture
la vraie culture papa pas celle des
bernard henri lévy et d'autres
d'autres clowns qui qui qui sont les
chouchous des médias parce que pour
plein de raisons donc
c'est vraiment lui
je suis vraiment triste quand je vois ce
qui se passe
et j'espère je crois en
la force du peuple français
qui a
qui a fait une des plus belles
révolution et qui a qui a aussi fait
d'autres révolution culturelle qui a
quand quand je vois à l'esprit qu'ils
avaient les écrits qui avait les
graffitis de mai 68
quand je vois là la solidarité que là
que la france a su montrer pour des
pour des causes comme la révolution
cubaine ou bien comme allende au chili
le premier est le vrai en septembre
je me dis que ça peut pas s'évaporer
c'est pas aussi loin que ça
je pense qu'il ya un problème aussi dans
le système éducatif en france parce que
même les enfants sont au lycée français
donc quand je les vois rarement ce n'est
pas au liban et que je vois ce qui ce
qui leur apparaît je me dis que c'est
c'est triste aussi qu' il ya
il ya des choses que
les pédagogues comme pédagogue font des
erreurs cc des générations entières qui
sont sacrifiés c'est il faut venir un
peu aux bonnes c'est pas très
progressiste que je vais dire pour un
quelqu'un qui l'a toujours été mais il
faut parfois y ait de bonnes vieilles
méthodes qui sont en train d'être perdue
que beaucoup de laxisme n'a jamais créé
de
grandeur que rien dans ce monde n'a été
créé avec des fainéants avec des gens
qui n'ont pas envie de se lever tôt
qu'ils n'ont pas envie de se battre qui
qui ne voit pas grand
[Musique]
viva la révolution dit
petite démonstration
il faut pas avoir recours aux armes
c'est le dernier recours c'est pas kaka
s'est pas c'est pas quelque chose qu'il
faut faire
on voit qu'à washington et à ce grand
problème de la drogue et yale des
sociales des médecins toutes sortes
experts qui disent que
il faut vraiment changer la loi et
surtout pour commencer légaliser la
marijuana mais c'est un sujet interdit à
washington moi je suis le bleu par cet
exemple je pense qu'il ya il n'y a pas
d'autres très peu d'autres exemples de
parce que ce que les canadiens appelle
les procédures bayonne c'est à dire que
vous vous êtes bombardé de procès et une
file et même si vous gagnez vous perdez
quoi parce que le temps que vous passez
avec défend de temps je lui le monde
avance et puis il ya un espèce de
rouleau compresseur comme sade et
révélations sur la sphère prisme sont
intéressantes en titre déjà parce qu'on
a maintenant la preuve irréfutable
de cette surveillance et de son
caractère massif et généralisé
pendant dix ans on a collecté des
preuves des témoignages
[Musique]